hey guys I'm a big old voice from like
the whole time
hey guys I'm a big old chubby boy from
Canada I'm 16 years old yeah and I have
a little trouble with the ladies kind of
getting some advice on that keep me
anonymous
his name is Paragon ok Paragon oh that's
his photo generic dating advice oh she's
so very I would have bought them if I
wasn't I'm gonna say this right now and
say that you know the first real girl I
had sex with was 23 before that I only
had sex with prostitutes you know that
way yeah so when I want to tell the guy
is is that sometimes you kill it later
in life so at 23 I started doing
stand-up and I've talked about this
before and that's when it opened the
Gateway to my confidence because you
know I've always had like a these
glasses on that made me look like I
wouldn't perceive myself as being
unfuckable you know and stand up and
also just getting confident and getting
older it just made me you know realize
that I came to girls and I did sometimes
it just happens later in life you know
so this kid he's 16 mm-hmm Paragon he
said keep it honest I don't know but
that's really his name that's a good you
always got girls huh
no so you don't know me i couldnt get
nailed in woodshop really in high school
you didn't get any girls ask anybody who
knew me Loserville I was home
babysitting my brother on Saturday
nights never went to a high school dance
ever never had a girlfriend exam was the
shortest kid in my entire high school
okay yeah after high school I went to
college and I grew 10 inches and then I
had this guy that in he was the he was a
popular kid in high schools name was Tom
he's my best friend to this day 31 years
30s he lived down the street from me
Houston Vigo's he rose and mom I'm
having some people over so I'd go over
there although I could hear the popular
kids going what is he doing
I could hear them yeah he's like he's
cool [ __ ] off he's cool well and he just
stuck up for me and I never really did
anything but he just like what and one
day came up and I was playing basketball
with myself just doing missing them
the balls Anthony he goes hey Rosenbaum
are you going to college I'm like ah I
was thinking about working at Sunoco gas
stations with this guy Charlie five
bucks an hour or working at Wesselman x'
grocery stores of sacker that's what I
did for three years
and he goes why don't you go to Western
Kentucky and we'll roommate we'll be
roommates and I go okay and I walked in
the house and I applied for the college
and I got in and he was always the guy
who was like going this guy's funny
listen to his impression this and he
slowly like he was the one person left
so what I say Paragon is there is
someone in your life probably right now
who loves you who believes in you cares
about you yeah and if not you're gonna
find that person you're gonna find your
little group of people that understand
you and get you and just love you for
you and that could take a couple years
or maybe it's now but you just gotta
take it slowly you're 16 you're not 68
you got the rest of your life man just
take it slowly brother when you just
said we're talking us now I think I
don't over you but somebody told me a
story once where he was in New York and
an elevator making it with somebody and
then they came in the elevator was that
you know I never came in an elevator
okay is that it thank you so much
Michael for coming and this is a tree
can I come back yeah 100 [ __ ] percent
in fact I'm gonna promote it now Michael
will be opening for me
well your mortgage now buy your tickets
now you're doing it you're doing it oh
it's for shows I got a good night I
gotta go over the UCB you guys yeah
thanks guys pastor Wednesday yeah guys
follow me at twitter M Rosenbaum 711
yeah on the Facebook Rollo my boy on
Twitter Instagram watch his show on
pastor and just this guy is all around
one of the best okay everyone you
bye-bye miss you falls on Instagram at
Tiger belly on Twitter at the Tiger
belly emails any questions like the
Tiger belly at gmail.com
[Music]